alright man so this is this is I think
three years in the making
yeah I first came across your story I
laugh every time I think about this I I
wish I first became familiar with you
through that November project
documentary when I was prepping to have
Brogan yellow and interestingly Brogan
as he's want to do from time to time
sends me video messages text messages as
I'm sure he does yes see you as well so
I got one of those today sent him back a
video and said that you were coming in
and he said that you guys often have a
chuckle because I brought you up in the
course of that podcast but I didn't say
your name and so we brushed up against
the name drop but it didn't actually
happen yeah I was super you would
mention that transgender athlete from
the right wing guy maybe do that maybe I
don't know what I think and I think I
tweeted you and said I always almost
mentioned oh yeah sorry about that well
you know maybe I'll go back and edit it
and and you know ever since that
experience like I cottoned onto your
story and I've been following everything
that you've been doing ever since and as
I just mentioned to you before we even
started we have been endeavoring to try
to make this happen for a long time and
I think you know experiences dictated
that these things happen when they're
supposed to happen and I think we're in
a really interesting moment right now
that makes the timing of this
conversation I think potentially much
more impactful than it would have been
previously yeah I think we're here in
the right moment right now right one
thing that uh that's been renting space
in my head is as you know I had Kendra
little on the show a little while back
and you tweeted like oh I'm so excited
to hear this and then there was nothing
after that and I and I've been so I've
been like I've been like you know going
oh man did I did did I not handle that
correctly did I miss
speak or misstep and so before we even
get into your story and
than many things I want to talk to you
about like how did that go for you was
that did I navigate that conversation
appropriately given your who you are and
your perspective on all of this oh yeah
absolutely so Kendra story is can I feel
much better
yeah no hit me to validate listen I
always need to validate no no I get it I
mean I did set that up like I was gonna
say something else about it I'm probably
god that's like I got nothing
Olympic Trials like man I've been
racking my head thinking my credit I did
I go wrong there like I thought I
handled it with kid gloves and yeah you
really didn't and I think that's one of
the things that I've always appreciated
about you rich is that I think that you
come to these conversations with open
heart and open mind to learn and to sort
of tease out different things for your
listeners and so I was really happy with
the way that that that that came off and
at the same time it's very different
yeah under sex is not sugar and you know
there were things within there that that
aren't applicable to trans Africa or
aren't applicable to my story and of
course you know I get the next bit of
time here with you right sort all that
out yeah and I think I think I said it
in that conversation but it bears
repeating which is that these things get
conflated intersex and and transgender
and they're very different things yeah
absolutely
we're seeing a lot of conversations
crossing I specific specifically at the
elite level when we have caster Semenya
come up and International Olympic policy
on transgender athletes and it's not the
same so there's a lot to dive in there
right so first of all congratulations on
on the Olympic Trials I know it didn't
go as you wished it would have and also
the New York Times piece that just came
out amazing yeah thank you it's pretty
crazy and my favorite part of the New
York Times article was the other race
Walker saying was it harder to come out
as a transgender athlete or as a race
Walker it was a very fun yeah you know
it's funny because at that time I had
not yet come out as a race Walker right
for something I was like wait what like
I read that I didn't even know like I've
sort of been paying attention you
but a little bit at arm's length and so
I wasn't even aware of that part of this
whole thing yeah and it was really vague
and I was intentionally vague about it
in my social media even after my first
race and my first national championship
that I kind of was really vague about it
and I think part of that was I wasn't
exactly sure how far I was gonna go in
this and how seriously I was committing
to it and you know I was just trying to
sort out my own sort of thoughts about
it you were at the Olympic Trials yeah
yeah yeah you know yeah it was I only
know a few transgender people but you're
definitely the first race Walker I've
ever met yeah and see I think I think
that's it I wasn't ready to fully commit
my identity to being that of a race
Walker because I'm I've been so involved
in the multi-sport community right
already telling people I'm a do athlete
I have to explain that you know
racewalking go straight to mall walking
which is a whole other conversation of
communication but I think it's it's
awesome because it is a you know there
are a lot of laughs associated with it
but I'll tell you I think race walking
is harder than running is it well the so
the idea is at all times one foot has to
have contact with the pit or both feet
have to be in contact with the pavement
or one foot one foot yes that would be
really hard shuffling I guess yeah one
foot so how do you even develop that
technique I mean you just stumbled into
this sport super recently and you had
this crazy ascension yeah so I started
in about May and suffered a knee injury
within like ten days of a starting race
walking so I really started training in
June and qualified or posted my time
that got me into the trials in October
and have been battling injury since then
right so it's been a very short amount
of time you know that the movement is
not natural and I think I said that a
number of times in my race to myself
like no human is made to move like this
unless you actually know the technique
and then you know these guys are flying
who are posting up a 350 time for 450k
while walking
that's one photo that's pretty crazy
it's it's a yeah
it's a weird like hip jiggle thing yeah
it's how do you even learn that
technique I think I'm still working on
it yeah yeah and how did they police
that over 50k like well somebody just
started to break into a run in the
middle of the race there can't be judges
all along the way making sure that that
foot is always on oh they're always
making contact well for perspective so
the when I qualified the first race I
did 50k was a two kilometer loop this
race for the trials was a 1.25 kilometer
loop with judges everywhere and you know
it's sort of a an out and back and so
the judges are looking on both sides and
since only 15 competitors compete in the
Olympic Trials and then there was an
invitational as well yeah that started
later you know it was very easy for them
to keep eyes on everybody if somebody
does start to break form there are
warning paddles that come up you get
three warnings and then you have a time
penalty and then on the fourth warning
you are pulled from the race I see so
how many were in the field trials 15 is
the cap that's it oh so they only take
50 so it's not a time standard is 15 yet
so there is a time standard and when
people don't meet the time standard then
they fill the rest of the field
to 15 I think that's the ideals are very
small yeah yeah it must be you know a
pretty tight-knit community there just
can't be that many people that are out
doing this yeah I've been super pleased
with how welcomed I've felt and and I've
been in the race walking community there
were you know the guy who asked me if I
came out as a race Walker hadn't heard
about my story prior to showing up at
the race we chatted for about 30
kilometers of that race and everyone I
just had the sense like everyone wants
to see me succeed they want school you
know they want more people to join race
walking they want the word to get out
and that's really a tight-knit community
well you have really made your mark on
not just the transgender community and
and and you know how that works within
sports but really on sports overall in
general like it's it's really remarkable
the level of advocacy that you shoulder
and the extent to which you really have
created change
it's really something so I wanna I want
to explore all of that but let's
contextualise it by taking it back and
hearing the superhuman origin story yeah
I grew up playing girls and women's
sports so I was assigned female at birth
was raised and socialized as a little
girl and grew up playing girls and
women's sports I was a three-sport
all-conference athlete in high school
grew up in suburbs of Chicago suburbs of
Chicago until about high school and then
moved up to Wisconsin hmm yeah you know
going from a large suburb large school
to a class of 25 students it was
shocking but that's what you do there
you play sports and so it was season to
season the season and that's are just
the traditional sort of basketball
baseball kind of thing
yeah polygon basketball softball right
you know that was that was life
yeah and that was how I made friends
that was how I found my community there
and really at that time you know I
didn't even have the word transgender on
my radar when I was a young person I
didn't know anybody in high school who
identified as lesbian gay bisexual
transgender or queer in very small
school 99 students in the high school in
total Wow and it's 300 from K through 12
they've actually shut down the school
because there are so few people who are
up there right and you know it doesn't
allow for a lot of diversity yeah and so
this was really not on my radar and what
I knew about the queer community about
the trans community was what I saw on TV
and at that time you know this is not a
lot Maury Povich and Jerry Springer and
they were not positive representations
or accurate representations of what it
means to be trans and in most cases I
was only seeing transgender women in in
movies or on reality TV and this was
like pre l-word probably even yeah and I
actually never I didn't have that
channel whatever it was and I'm not a
big TV person sir
amidst all of that and and sort of
socially like how was that I mean you
you said you know that that you had a
sense that you were different that dates
back to as early as you being four right
yeah so how did that translate in terms
of how you kind of navigated your social
life throughout junior high in high
school I think my plan was to make
myself as busy as possible so that no
one really got a chance to know me
uh-huh I was too busy living starred oh
yeah absolutely but I was friends with
everybody you know people in high school
in college would call me a social
butterfly but I could go to any of the
different friend groups or cliques and
fit in well and then back out and go
somewhere else yeah and I really think
that was a strategy not only to not
allow other people to get to know me but
so that I didn't have to spend the time
really thinking about who I was as a
person uh-huh I'm thinking about myself
and as long as you were out on the field
like it was a comfortable place where
you felt like you were accepted yeah
always
I mean I think from my earliest memories
were from sports and from fitting in and
and finding friends because I was a good
athlete a great teammate and a good
leader and you know my willingness to
sacrifice for the team it was always a
positive right part of being a teammate
and so that was a really easy place for
me to fit in and and to find out more
about myself you know right now I would
say even as an adult I all of the things
that I love about myself in terms of my
values in my work ethic you know in my
thought process and how I communicate
with other people
you know my perspective on winning and
losing goal-setting all of that comes
from those very early yeah lessons they
that I learned in sporting yeah and it
seems like that that sensibility was
allowed you to kind of transcend
whatever you know sense of difference
that you felt or may have you know been
perceived to have by your classmates and
your teammates because you were such a
good team member it that that like took
care of everything else right yeah I
hate it okay yep and that was my
solution or that feeling that I had that
I didn't quite fit in it was already
hard enough going to that small school
from you know Sabra Brava City and
dressing differently and I was listening
to different music and had different
fashion sense and interests and you know
when I'm there with them it was like a
two-year time gap where it was my end of
sophomore year before people started to
listen to what I was listening to or
dressed the way I was dressing and so I
just felt that I was so out of place
there but but sports and that common
goal of wanting to succeed as a team was
really what grounded me in that
community yeah was it a sense that
you're just you were just a tomboy
initially yeah I think so but I you know
I think just because I didn't have the
language or the terminology to assign to
it like I knew I wasn't like my brother
so I have a brother who's a year and a
half younger than me and growing up I
knew that I wasn't like him and I also
knew that people didn't treat me the way
that they treated him or give me the
same opportunities that they gave him
and so I felt that difference but also
when I looked at the girls in my class I
knew that I wasn't like them yeah and
you know I had just hindsight is so
interesting because there are all these
moments where it it all lines up for me
every single you know part of my
childhood of what I was interested in
and how I behaved and you know have all
of these memories of adults telling me
you can't do this because little girls
don't do this you can't dress like this
you can't play this sport you shouldn't
act like this and every part of me felt
that was authentic expression mm-hmm and
I wasn't learning that from other places
it was just truly who I was right and
short of sports I would suspect that
that would be you know it had to be
lonely right feeling like you didn't fit
into either of those categories sports
being the refuge but short of sports you
can begin to see why somebody who's
having a similar experience to you would
start to develop you know depression and
other kind of mental you know problems
around that that feeling of isolation
and and distance yeah and I think that's
a very common thing that we hear with
not just queer athletes trans athletes
but the lgbtq+ community in general is
that there are so many of us who feel
like we are the only one
it's going through this experience mmm
and I think it's really that feeling and
and I can't say in high school that I
really felt that because I did such a
good job of putting my energy into
sports into extracurricular activities
the yearbook and the newspaper and
photography and and extra jobs and
anything that I could do to keep myself
from having to spend that time right of
feeling loneliness and discomfort and
disconnection you know well but looking
back that was all false it was all false
connections it wasn't real authentic
because I didn't want people to see the
real me I didn't want people to really
get to know the real me because I had
received messages for ten years at that
point that that who I was as a person
was not okay and it was not the way that
I was supposed to be yeah and I don't
think that way this the sports part is
authentic right I mean on some level
it's a mask right to keep people at bay
oh yeah but it was really a true love
for me yeah it's where I felt most like
myself uh-huh so you graduate from high
school you go to northern Michigan
University yep I'm from Michigan
sorry where's Northern Michigan
University you pee it's in Marquette oh
wow yeah all the way up oh my good yeah
yeah that is I mean you went from a
small school in Wisconsin to like an
incredibly isolated community up there
right yeah I did and it might not a lot
of diversity up there yet except the and
there's only right the thing is is that
that was except for the athletes there
wasn't a lot of diversity but that's
more racial diversity there wasn't a lot
of diversity in terms of lgbtq+
acceptance either and it also points to
the time period like people just were
really talking about that when I was in
college and we're talking 1998 to 2003
five wonderful years in in Michigan that
people just weren't talking about it and
and it was it was a very different time
so how do you begin to piece this
together for yourself and and and you
know start to own your identity it
didn't happen
when I was there in hindsight again
looking back you know my dream was to
play college basketball
and I had hopes of going to college and
playing and having my name on the back
of Jersey and being you know having that
that athletic experience and when the
time came to make a decision I had so
many different excuses and chose not to
play basketball
what do you mean excuses like you were
you were afraid or oh absolutely but but
how that how that came out was you know
I'm a first generation college student
no one in my family has ever gone to
school and navigating that process to
even go to school was a challenge for me
and I knew that there was a huge
investment not just of my own money but
also of my time and you know my family's
energy and so I knew I'd have to pay for
school myself and thought okay I'm not
getting a scholarship I'm going to have
to have jobs so I can't be an athlete
and pay for school at the same time and
I thought you know this is a huge
investment in in myself and I want to
get a great job after college and you
know if I'm not paying attention to my
academics yeah that's not gonna happen
so yeah like how are your how are your
folks growing up in what way well in the
sense of you know raising you there must
have been you know some idea that you
were a bit you know askew from a
traditional notion of you know what they
probably expected their daughter to look
like at that time right yeah so how have
they navigated that whole thing yeah you
know it's interesting I've I've never
really had a conversation about my with
my mom about this and I think that when
I finally understood my identity I was
terrified to tell her she raised me as a
single parent dad left the picture sort
of in and out from the age of 8 and he
is still around but but we haven't been
in communication for about 15 20 years
maybe and and it was not related to my
identity yeah at that time I didn't know
I was trans and I I wasn't out as queer
but you know for my mom I think when I
did come out as trans I think she
would've been more surprised if I said I
was gonna wear a dress the next day yeah
then to kind of tell her and explain to
her what transgender identity meant but
even I was raised in a very loving
and she encouraged me to play sports
despite my injuries when I was a kid I
often heard like you were not meant to
play sports you know with the twisted
ankle or bruised ribs or whatever but
you know I I felt like I had full
support from her to participate in
sports in terms of how I showed up in
the world I think that I definitely
didn't line up with the vision of what
she had for a little girl and you know
whether that was going to clothing
shopping at the start of the school year
and wanting to go to the boys section
and her saying come over here or people
in in stores saying your son and her
correcting them and saying that's my
daughter mm-hmm
you know I think that that I can only
guess probably brought up a lot of
things for her mm-hmm but you haven't
really fully fleshed it out with her
yeah yeah no because it's like it's just
too sensitive you think yeah and I think
that there's a lot a lot of things that
have been unsaid between the two of us
and and when I came out you know she was
so incredibly supportive it was I was
good terrified to tell her and delayed
telling her because I didn't want it to
be like you know Thanksgiving that's
when Chris came out as a man right like
I didn't want it to be attached to a
holiday I'm not seeing her all the time
and really wanted to make sure that I
expressed to her how important this was
how significant this is and how real
this is for me and you know she's the
one who named me and so you know I
thought like you know she had a daughter
and two sons and now she has three sons
mm-hmm and that changes things for her
that's a transition for her as well and
how she talks in her small community
about you know when people come back and
don't know and say how's your daughter
you know what is the response to that
right so I'm very aware that there are
challenges for her to deal with that I
will never know yeah things about things
are changing though they've changed
quite a bit I mean I feel like the their
permissiveness and the the education you
know peace to all of this has has grown
so much
and you know just the word transgender
and the kind of you know acceptance that
we're seeing in certain parts of America
and the world is so much more than I'm
you know obviously there's a long way to
go here yeah but it is interesting that
this is being talked about in a way that
is unprecedented you know I'm older than
you like this was you know I mean like
I'm I'm trying really hard to not be
like the okay boomer guy here but but
you know it's a lot different now than
it was you know when you were growing up
and certainly when I was growing up and
and I'm interested in why you think like
this moment is happening now yeah
visibility is a powerful tool for social
change and the more visibility that we
have the more awareness is created and
it's really been interesting since I
came out in 2010 came out publicly in
The Advocate magazine New York Times
article shortly after and that was sort
of what you know stepped me into this
public identity as an out trans man
which is a decision that you only make
one time with the internet right and
forever the transgender athlete there
has to be a hard decision it was it was
incredibly hard yeah it was it was a
very challenging decision because part
of me just wanted to go somewhere and
live the life that I knew that I was
meant to live to switch jobs switched
communities and just like be the dude
that I wanted right but your interest in
sport and your desire to be this you
know elite you know professional athlete
kind of mandated that you be somewhat
public about it because you would have
to change your classification and there
was gonna have to be you know like to
change your name and then that
classification when you're kind of
moving your way up the ranks and
triathlon and people knew who you were
prior that's gonna require some public
visibility yeah but I think even more
than that it would it really wasn't
about that I thought that I was going to
lose sport and when I knew my identity
when I knew that I was trans I waited
over a year and a half to actually come
out because I was
terrified of losing my ability to
compete when I finally made that
decision to publicly come out what it
really was was I didn't want anybody
else to feel the way that I felt to feel
like there was no place in sport for
them that there was nobody that they
could look to you and see a possibility
or a reflection of themselves when I was
when I was thinking about transition I
didn't see any trans men competing with
men and more than that I didn't see
transgender athletes in general I mean
I'm not the first transgender athlete
I'm the first public trans a athlete but
there was a big gap between other out
trans athletes and and my coming out in
2010 right all right well going back
you're at northern Michigan you're
you're hustling multiple jobs doing that
whole thing and when does your night you
make the decision and not play
basketball but how do you find your way
back into sports so I had a job in the
Student Center serving food and one day
the college mascot walked in with the
cheerleading team and I looked at my
coworker and said I'm gonna do that and
it's the northern Michigan mascot its
Wildcat Willie okay
Wildcat Willie so I bring this up
because I got my NCAA Division one
letter and cheerleading which i think is
hilarious because because I did a year
in Harris as the mascot and while people
might say that's not a very athletic
part you know I was working out the
cheerleading team going to practices and
going to games but all of it was done in
this really safe way where I was in full
costume behind a gigantic mask
no one did anyone know who the mascot
was my the other mascots and the
cheerleading team my college roommate
didn't know for a very long time yeah in
the Internet age that probably wouldn't
be possible yes correct but at that time
it was it was top-secret and I'm gonna
sort of that Disneyland mentality never
have the head off and for me that was
really it was awesome because I got to
connect with people in that college
environment in that sports environment
and you know everybody wants like a
picture with the mascot and I in
reflecting saw that that was one of the
only times I smiled in photos at that
time period in my life was when I was in
a mask and no one could see me hmm
because I felt like I didn't want to be
seen outside of that like even for me
now I don't look back at old photos and
I don't post old photos I you know that
was a very painful time for me hmm and I
couldn't have expressed that I think
outwardly at that time I couldn't put
words to my pain but looking back on it
I know that you know I was hurting and I
didn't know why yeah it's it's life
meets metaphor right like you were
literally inside a costume yeah so that
you could be in the world and yet not be
seen yeah and I felt the most
comfortable there and you know Wildcat
Willie is a is a boy Wildcat well it's
crazy it's almost like your subconscious
chose that yeah and I think my
subconscious chose quite a few things
that all line up for me now mmm like
what else you know I think just the way
that I navigated sports and that you
know in college used to come back to how
did I participate after I chose not to
play basketball because there's
basketball and then there's women's
basketball and for me it was that I
didn't feel like being on the women's
team fit me and I couldn't say that but
that's you know I didn't want to go into
a women's locker room I didn't want to
be a part of a group where people are
saying hey ladies you know let's go
girls I chose to do intramural sports
and participate in anything that was
co-ed anything that I could show up
already in my clothes and not have to
use a locker room and you know be out
there with other people but not have to
be on that gendered team right
it lets you off the hook of having to
answer that question or even have to
deal with any of that yeah and that's
really how I got into running after
school as well it was that that was
something that I could do straight from
my door to go out and not have to
interact with people and eventually when
I did want to compete that I could do
that but in an individual way as opposed
to being a part of a gender to team
right were you fast right of the right
away when you started running no no no
no I don't think so
really yeah I don't have you know I
think I really had to work for it so the
way that I got into running was in my
last year of school I had to
mini-strokes and yeah and so I suffered
a lot of health issues in that last
fifth year of college and strokes in
college that's very unusual yeah and you
know it's one of these things that now
when I talk about it like I wish that I
had the understanding of health and you
know what it means to be healthy and
take care of yourself because I just
wasn't asking the right questions at
that time and you know again looking
back part of me probably didn't care if
something bad happened to me and I never
felt like I was depressed and I never
really felt like I was isolating myself
but I certainly was mm-hmm and you know
that sort of physical manifestation of
the stress I was feeling and you know
whatever else caused that was really
what sort of put me on this path of
wanting to see how far I could push my
body and that was sort of when I came
back in to run he started it into
running after that was seeing a Chicago
Marathon banner when I was in the city
and saying I'm gonna do that you know me
not being able to run a quarter mile at
that point saying that that's what I
want to work I'm holding out this
aspiration like this is this is
potentially you know way forward for me
so was there like a level of
self-sabotage with your health or was it
just kind of harboring all of that
stress you know whether it was
unconscious or conscious that dissonance
between true identity and and how you
were you know making choices about how
to navigate the world that you think
precipitated like the strokes and these
health problems that you were having it
was absolutely self-sabotage yeah and
you know it just it didn't manifest for
me in cutting or you know
self-harm like that you know I think it
was that I wasn't sleeping
and I wasn't eating well and I wasn't
drinking water and you know it was
really stressing myself out trying not
to think about myself and my identity
and or how I fit in in this world and I
think there's something about being
faced with being on the edge of your
freshman year of life you know you hit
that final year of school and say all of
this identity that I have here as a
student leader as a student athlete as a
person who works here or does this
activity community service whatever all
of that is going to go away and when I
leave here I'm gonna have a piece of
paper and what and I did not put time
into that what and that was a very
frightening situation to be in knowing
that the end was near of school and that
I would have to figure all of this out
so you had no sense of what you wanted
to do after college I had no job lined
up uh-huh I had no home lined up and my
now wife who I was kind of often on
seeing but I wouldn't admit that I liked
her sent me a key to her apartment in LA
and you know seven days before
graduation I get this key in the mail
and says we can be roommates I packed my
car after school and drove over here
with no job Wow no idea of what I would
do and you met your wife in college
right yeah she was visiting a friend I
said oh so she wasn't a fellow student
yeah gotcha yeah so you came here at see
I thought you went to New York after
college you came here yeah I came here
lived in Koreatown and then Oh Venice
and then moved to Chicago for graduate
school right and would you study in
graduate school I studied higher
education so yeah you know I just had I
had such a great sort of like Saved by
the Bell experience when I was in
college in terms of my activities and
you know being a part of different
groups and organizations I said that the
other day to a group of students in
college and they had no idea what Saved
by the Bell was so I feel like they're
ready to change that reference but you
know I had a really great experience
being in the student newspaper in the
yearbook and the radio and all of that
and I sort of felt like I had an art
degree and that's I got a graphic design
degree I was working in newspaper in
Santa Monica as an art
director and just didn't love the
deadline life and I thought you know
that is probably around the time where I
had this sort of calling to give back to
other people and I thought that was the
best way for me to get back would be to
go and work at a college and allow other
students to have the experience that I
had right so this is early 2000s 2000
year for some I got yeah right and so
meanwhile running or what's going on
sports-wise yep running here nothing
organized just running along the beach
and the boardwalk and you know I think
also trying to come back to my health
you know after the mini-strokes and then
being put on painkillers and struggling
and grappling with what bat meant for me
and you know I was never addicted to
painkillers but I certainly don't think
I was using them appropriately and I
think part of that was self soothing you
know - I wasn't drinking I wasn't doing
drugs it works that way initially yeah
yeah exactly exactly
and I think I saw that in myself because
my dad was an alcoholic and I've always
been very conscious and aware of
relationship to that sort of distancing
of my reality I guess well you can't put
on the mascot costume anymore yeah so
what else you gonna put in front of you
to you know to kind of mute that noise
or create a little buffer between you
and the world yeah and my time here
which was about a year and a half was
really trying to figure that out before
I went to grad school I really struggled
because how do you make friends as an
adult you know it was something that I
didn't really think about but I made all
my friends in my residence hall or in my
organizations or in my you know sports
groups that when I came here with no one
aside from Jen you know I just didn't
know what to do and so yeah and LA can
be very lonely in that way yeah you know
it's it's really it's really hard to
connect with people here I think yeah
but I think that that was the time
period where I started to put the pieces
together and a lot of that was due to my
relationship with Jen that when we would
go out people would see us
a lesbian couple and that word never
resonated with me right I can't blame
them though
yeah no no yeah yeah and I think there's
something about you know people want to
assign labels to people and you know
think about bisexual identity when we
see someone you know a man in
relationship with a man we never assume
he's bisexual people just say oh he's
gay you know
so there-there is complexity to our
relationships that aren't always
accurately labeled yeah when people
would say that or you know I have some
distinct memories of people saying hey
ladies to us and me just feeling like
you know it didn't sit well with me it
felt wrong and it had a very physical
reaction for me and I think that was the
you know the first parts of really
having to put it together and figure it
out and you know in hindsight I can say
the reason that didn't fit was that I
didn't identify as a woman right and so
and did she did shed that's how you say
her name is that I mean how is she you
know was she aware of this at the time
like here's this is what's amazing like
so Jen has been with you throughout this
entire thing right you got married you
met her you know prior to transitioning
and all of that and she's been kind of
like the steady constant and all of this
but on some level I suspect she must
have I mean did you guys have
conversations about this or like how was
she what was her awareness level in
terms of you know what you were
struggling with yeah I think I have
blinked out on a big part of this and
I'm sure Mike's my explanation
experience is very different than her
perspective on it you know initially
when I started talking about our
relationship and about my transition I
would say transition is a transition for
everybody right so like how my
relationship might change with my mom
right so he changes her her view and her
position to me and how she talks about
me and it was never like that version
you know she fell in love with me as a
person and we had this amazing
experience of getting to know each other
sort of through written word through
messaging and through letters and things
like that like super old-school
and and I think that we got a different
sense of who each other were and so I
think that she already she always knew
that there was something about me and I
think that when she started to see my
own discomfort in those situations when
we're out in public or when we're
together you know that's really what
prompted her I assume to say to me you
know I think that you need to put some
time and energy into thinking about your
identity and that's really how I was
sort of you know gently guided in the
right direction of actualizing and
talking about it and figuring it out
right that's that's very unique and
amazing yeah and to have her throughout
this process I mean I think I would
imagine most people don't have somebody
like that yeah dealing with this kind of
thing yeah I I think so and and I think
that that is a real fear for people in
our community to say like you know there
are so many things out there there are
House bills and policies and laws that
say that we don't deserve love and
respect that we don't deserve
protections and equal rights and so to
have somebody who not only you know
loves me and respects me and protects me
but also is here for me to grow and
encouraging me to grow and just to be my
best most authentic self yeah yeah
that's a really yeah not just not just
someone who is understanding but also
encouraging you like pushing you in that
direction
yeah and I never felt pushed and I never
felt forced and I never felt like like
you know there was no there was no force
behind it it was gentle guiding you know
like she had it more information than I
had she had more information about the
queer community she had been around more
people had more diversity in their life
and so I think it was really awesome
that she you know was able to see that I
was struggling or however she would
phrase it and to sort of point me in the
direction of books and you know magazine
articles and and things I should watch
on YouTube or so she was living out here
but where's she from
Chicago Chicago so more like urban
metropolitan
yeah she snatches this person from
northern Michigan and you know rural
Wisconsin yeah like I'm gonna I'm gonna
like you know edify this person I don't
think that was it I was not a project
for her but but imagine like listen if
you're in an intimate relationship and
you're not you know authentically who
you are there's gonna be a barrier to
intimacy right because you're not you're
not a fully integrated person yeah if
you're like kind of walking around in
the world feeling disconnected because
you're not sure who you're you are
you're supposed to be maybe you do but
you're afraid to be that person yeah and
I think that that's what was so magical
about her and remains magical about her
is that her is her encouragement for me
to figure that out and to be my best
most integrated authentic self too so
that we can have a deeper and more
meaningful relationship uh-huh
so you guys go to Chicago together when
you go out at school she went to New
York for grad school and I went to
Chicago hmm so it was a year of hard
Justin's kind of thing for a while
yep yeah yeah and then at some point you
did move to New York though right yes
Wow I was like I know you're you've been
in Chicago in New York but I don't know
at the time timeline on all that yeah
one year of graduate school in Chicago
and then I got an internship at Cornell
University in New York and gotten job
opportunity shortly after I decided to
skip my second year of grad school and
take this amazing opportunity in New
York where I would live rent-free for
the duration of my time that's not bad
not bad yeah yeah well a world must have
opened up to you when you got to New
York City you know it didn't it didn't
and it was really interesting that even
in there was this awareness that there
were more people potentially in the
world like me and like us like more
queer people and I remember seeing at
that time to say 2005-2006 you know two
men holding hands in the street and
being like oh wow like it it was on my
radar right and I ain't paying for me
when I would see same-sex couples or
what a queer families and that was a
different experience but it wasn't close
enough to me
and what I mean by that is even in being
there I didn't know any trans people in
real life almost all the way up until my
transition there were very few and no
one that I had that I felt like I could
go to and ask questions and sort of
bounce ideas off of or or even be close
enough to get a sense of what that meant
for them so walk me up to you know the
epiphany that you know this is the
person that you're meant to be and then
the actions that you then take to kind
of make that happen and I'm sure it was
a lot of things leading up to it right
but I remember distinctly watching
YouTube videos for hours hours and hours
of people documenting their transition
so it was people mostly young people
mostly white people mostly college age
or younger who would go through and just
have weeks and weeks and years of videos
of like documenting what coming out was
like what getting hormones was like the
changes that they're experiencing on
testosterone and and all of that I
remember really diving into all of the
materials that were available online at
that time and at the same time trying to
figure out within myself and sort of in
my relationship how I could exist in
this world and and fellini me because it
was such a challenge at that time to
leave my house every day I mean it
really got to the point where I would
say I felt like a video game character
and would leave on full power and that
it'd be like hey ladies or if where's
Chris have you seen her you know and my
power meter would go down and down and
down and by the end of the day I felt
like a shell of a person I would
recharge and you know go out into the
world and do it again and it didn't feel
like a good way to do this and were you
dressing in a in a more masculine way at
that time always yeah I've always been
masculine of Center I'd say and yeah you
know when I actually did come out not
much about me changed except my pronouns
it was really like I had been living as
myself for a very long time
was more than mirror in the reflection
of how other people in the world saw me
and treated me and responded to me right
and around this time you start getting
into triathlon though right that was
when you're in New York yeah that was
start competing you know as a as a woman
yeah so I did do the marathon worked my
way up in New York City races and did a
marathon did an ultra marathon 60k
around Central Park and did not want to
do a 50 or 100 miler I thought what's
the next challenge and you know this
going back to the mini-strokes is really
that mindset of like how far can i push
myself the training and the racing
mostly the training was a way for me to
focus that energy and sort of do what I
did when I was a kid of like feeling
most like myself in sport I bought a
bike taught myself how to swim did my
first triathlon and won but I won your
first triathlon I want my group when
you're in later age group I've and I was
two people then yes Brent too
embarrassed to tell people because it
was in the women's category and that was
sort of like a moment of saying okay
like sport which I loved so much and who
I am as a person have intersected here
and I'm having a real challenge a real
challenging time talking about it with
other people
yeah like this boiling point where it's
no longer tolerable tolerable for you to
kind of you know manage this duality
yeah and and I think with that awareness
it was heightened because then I would
be at the starting line of races and you
know and triathlons they often separate
the waves and so I'd be in the pink cap
with the women standing there and having
people look at me you know in my inner
monologue is there wondering why I'm
here and I could hear some of them
saying like why is that person here and
I just didn't fit them the mold of a
typical woman what they expected you to
look like yeah yeah I think I've always
presented masculine ly I've always had
that energy about me and
you know I people could pick up on it
right so when does the decision arise
that you know begin at the transition
yeah the the moment was my birthday when
I was turning 29 and for years leading
up to that my wife and I would have a
private dinner at home usually some Thai
takeout real low-key because I didn't
feel worthy of celebrating I didn't feel
like I was worthy of people knowing my
birthday and for so many years I
wouldn't tell people I wouldn't tell
people the month like I didn't I would
we wouldn't talk astrological signs
because I didn't want you to figure out
when my birthday was because I was just
so insightful
it is um yeah I mean it really is sad
and I love my birthday now and i also
celebrate my tea day so i feel like i
get i'm making them for it I'm doing
double celebrating but I didn't feel
like I should be celebrated or people
should pay attention to me and so we had
this small private thing that we did and
in New York we decided to go out to a
restaurant on my birthday one year and
we went to this you know dimly lit
crowded very loud Mexican restaurant on
the Lower East Side and you know I could
eat the chips and salsa off the table
next to me it was packed tight the
waiter came up and I think that they
said hey ladies can I take your order
and I ordered and then started to cry
and that to me was shameful I grew up in
a household that was you know suck it up
don't you know like don't cry don't be
emotional and it was taught to release
suppress that and then as an athlete
it's it's even elevated more where
you're not supposed to show pain don't
show weakness and so I had been
suppressing it for a long time
for so long and this was really the
breaking point I mean it's amazing to
think that this one person saying what
they would say to any table right and
that's what broke me hmm I made my way
out of the restaurant and spilled out
onto the street crying on the sidewalk
in New York City New York nobody cares
so people were flying by and another
crying person that's another crumble
that's all I'm broken you know
straighten tree
out here you know and that's really what
it was and cabs whizzing by and I mean
it was just like I felt invisible and
that's how I wanted to feel when we
finally got our food and took a trip
back home took it to go and I mean this
had been 30 minutes or longer than I
thought I've just been inconsolable and
when I finally could talk the only thing
that I could say was I never thought my
life would be like this like I couldn't
imagine living another year as that
person in that body in this life having
navigated the experiences that I've
navigated to that point and having
people respond to me
in the way that they had been and that
was the decision of like I have to do
this and if it means I'm going to lose
sport that's what it means because it's
more important for me to be comfortable
in the 95 percent of my life when I'm
not training you know you know we're
racing then to hold on to this idea that
I could be the athlete that I hoped I
could always be as a woman or or just
face those fears of like what will my
mom say what will my boss say and my
coworkers and you know the 500 students
that were living in my building and you
know like I felt like a lot of pressure
of worrying about other people's
expectations and the great irony of
course is that when you summon the
courage to face all of those things and
the fear about not being able to
continue to compete as an athlete and
and take the action to become a more
fully integrated self actualized person
in alignment with how you see yourself
in the world your your world has
exploded not only have you been allowed
to compete you've had success that I'm
sure you could have never you know even
predicted at that time yeah that's crazy
it really is and you know all of that
energy that I was putting into hiding
who I was all of that energy that I was
putting into worrying about what you
would think or what anybody else would
think about me well there's not the
starting line of a race or at my
workplace or at home or whatever all of
that energy I was able to put into being
who I truly am right I was able to put
that into my racing
to my training and and you know
eliminate all of those distractions and
it really opened up an entirely new
world for me yeah I must have been
cathartic yeah and it continues to be I
I continue to have moments where I'm
surprised that this is my life and in
some ways it's because I'm surprised I'm
still alive yeah you know I just in that
I didn't have plans for what I would do
after graduation I never saw myself
getting married you know I never saw
myself having a family or you know
having three amazing bunnies at home or
living you know like I never saw a
future for myself I never saw success in
a workplace or an idea of where I wanted
to go and because you didn't see a model
out there that you could mimic right
there was no there was no precedent and
no idea of what that would look like for
yourself yeah and so to be in a position
where I can be that for younger version
of me and for other people is really
incredible yeah so the transition for
you involved basically getting on
testosterone right and was there what
you know what what walk me through like
you know all right now I'm gonna put on
my okay boomer hat like walk me through
like what transition means cuz I know it
takes various forms for different people
yeah so transition there's not just one
way to transition and there's not just
okay there's no correct way to
transition it looks different for
everyone and I am a case study of one so
what my experience looked like was first
making a social transition social
transition can be changing name pronoun
restrooms that you use manners
mannerisms style of dress things like
that huh the second part of a transition
may include and it doesn't have to be
second just different category is a
medical transition and so that would be
maybe gender affirming surgeries top
surgery lower surgery hysterectomy
things like that or taking testosterone
treatment for me or cross hormone
therapy in and sometimes like vocal
therapy and might fall under that sort
of medical thing right and then there's
a legal Tran
so that would be changing legal
documents like a driver's license ID
passport Social Security birth
certificate so those are the three
different categories or buckets of
transition and you know people's paths
look different mine was initially so I
think it's important to say I never felt
like I was born in the wrong body or
trapped in the wrong body that was not a
part of my experience it is a very valid
experience for many trans people yeah
that seems to be like the sort of
catch-all yeah you know I would have
thought like well that's that's the
that's the experience right that's the
universal experience yeah it's not and
it's not no it's not and you know I
think that it's certainly that was the
messages that I got when I was younger
about trans people was you're trapped in
the wrong body for me it was really very
specifically I just did not like my
chest I did not like having breasts and
that was the one part of me that when I
thought about future me as a kid funny
story I had a drawing on my closet when
I was about 8 9 10 11 years old from a
muscle and fitness magazine that was
just a torso from like shoulders to
waste of a dude six-pack right and it
was on my closet like not like lusting
over but like I'm going to have that
uh-huh and that was the vision that I
had for myself that I would that I would
have that you know flat chest and
six-pack abs and well you got a funny I
do now
it was a long road it was we had made it
happen it was an unconventional path but
yeah in you know so that for me was the
first thing and I thought maybe if I
have top surgery which would be for me
it was a double mastectomy mm-hmm and
maybe if I did that that I would not you
know maybe maybe I would be good there I
think part of me was dragging my feet
and really trying not to fully commit to
transition because I was just worried
about existing in the world so I thought
that I could have top surgery have a
flat chest and I had been binding in my
chest for about a year and a half before
that when I had the realization that I
was trans so a binder is a compression
garment super tight and just flattens
out flattens upper chest and it was you
know
incredibly uncomfortable difficult to
breathe in sweaty and gross and yeah I
thought that having Top surgery may fix
my discomfort with myself at the same
time I thought maybe I would be okay
with people saying he sometimes and she
sometimes so I didn't fully commit to a
pronoun transition until I've had that
birthday moment and even then it
happened in stages for me you know first
with family and friends other friends
and my teammates and then at work much
later and then I started testosterone
after I had Top surgery I realized that
I was still not showing up in the world
the way that I saw myself and that was
the final step right and when you start
taking testosterone how long does it
take before you start to see changes and
what is what is that experience like
yeah changes happen slowly over time and
I think it's really funny because the
YouTube videos that I've watched I had
known sort of what was going to happen
so there is this sense of like being so
excited about change that you know I'm
like are my hands getting bigger like do
I have you know like examining for
facial hair or whatever it took about a
year for me to sort of settle into how
how I felt on testosterone and sort of
start to see the the changes which you
know you can see in comparison photos
but I wasn't seeing every day because
you know I'm seeing myself every day and
and I'm sure there's a there's like an
emotional transition of you know
acclimating to these changes you know
and also what was it like like did you
experience differences in in like how
you felt in your body like did your
energy change or like how you know what
is it and I mean it I'm trying to
imagine that experience yeah it felt it
felt very different in my skin and I
think part of it was in March I had Top
surgery and then had the recovery from
that so when I could finally lift my
arms and move around it was mid-april
and then June was when I started
testosterone so I was already in this
new body sort of trying to figure things
out when I started testosterone it
wasn't like the next day people started
calling me heel that's all right you
know so
there was a challenging thing of like I
felt like you know that wasn't day one
but it was day one of testosterone of
likes really starting the changes for me
and so it was significant but to that
point for years people were calling me
he sometimes in she sometimes and you
know I over time I realized that I was
becoming increasingly more comfortable
with the he and increasingly
uncomfortable with people saying she or
not knowing and you know I wanted to
make that shift but in those first
couple of months it wasn't automatic and
so then there was something that I did
and that I think a lot of trans people
did and do is like what am I doing wrong
to make you not see me the way that I
see myself so there was a lot of
self-criticism and critique and trying
to figure out how to show up in the
world in a way that would allow you to
call me he hmm so I think it was an
interesting thing of like not just so
you're you're taking responsibility for
that rather than like I'm demanding that
you call me by this proton pronoun yeah
and I did that and I did demand people
and you know had great allies who helped
me because it's really uncomfortable to
correct other people consistently about
my pronoun for me you know to show up
and say like actually rich it's it's P
right like that is I'm doing something
wrong for you not to see me in that way
that's the way that I expressed that and
took that so I had a really hard time
navigating that period of time where I
felt like I was becoming more of myself
and people weren't quite there with me
and so it was a lot of like you know how
I think it caused a social transition
for me in a way that I backed down from
later on so what I mean by that is I
knew what was gonna happen physically I
had a sense of what it would might might
be like to come out at work and with my
family and the thing that people didn't
talk about was male privilege and what
it would be like to show up in the world
as a man and what people look to you for
masculinity and in sort of there's a
right way and a wrong way to express max
masculinity or
there's I think particularly in sports
right we preference a certain type of
masculinity
even within cisgender men and so I was
trying to figure out like I don't think
I went hyper masculine I didn't start to
show up like that but I got try on a
bunch of dude hats to figure out which
kind of dude you were gonna be
absolutely what you're saying yeah yeah
yeah thank you for articulating that in
that way I think that was rhymed it down
to like yeah but I think that really was
it that that for so long I had one man
as in one thing right you know in that
idea like the idea we're like that you'd
you would projected into the future like
I want to be male I want to be a man but
maybe hadn't figured out what what that
meant specifically like what kind of man
yes you did you is that what you're
saying yeah and I think that it was that
I wasn't even that I was like I want to
be a man and that there's this image of
man right it was like I want to feel
more like myself right and I want people
to see me as meaning and and I found
that that over time that saying he and
and existing in male spaces was more
comfortable right I got you yeah okay so
as this is going on you're still
training for triathlons and all of that
right and yes probably a lot of
paperwork you're at yeah yeah right to
like make this transition complete yeah
so initially it was pretty easy but
painful to make the transition of
categories in both running and triathlon
it was basically like me contacting
organizations because there weren't no
policies in place at that time so I
would write to somebody and say I'm
transgender I want I've been competing
as female I want to compete as male how
do I do it and they're like well I don't
know we've never we've never dealt with
this right yes let me forward your
muscle jang-soo eight of my colleagues
who will then forward it on to more of
their folks so you know by the end of
the chain it was 40 people looped in on
my you know like me being out right so
when I when I and this was at a time
when I didn't feel comfortable being
fully out with a lot of people so trying
to figure out the policies will I be
able to compete
and you know how will I continue to fit
in sports was if that was a difficult
right so what was the first race that
you competed in as a male
it was Ironman Arizona oh man I'm sorry
I'm in Florida yeah Ironman Florida it
was my first Ironman it was my first
time running outside without a shirt on
like from the wet knee with the wet suit
off it was it was a very big race yeah
and so how did that feel to do that I it
felt incredible I was very well trained
for it I thought oh you're man anything
can happen right yeah well trained for
an iron were you living in a Manhattan
at that I was yeah yeah yeah yeah where
do you ride your bike like just in the
in the park or up Route nine across the
bridge yeah yeah and I was very close to
Central Park so lots of laps and that's
that peloton in Central Park during the
summer where they closed the roads as
well I mean that's you're playing with
your life with that thing yeah not so
much at that time I think now maybe but
yeah so and a lot of trainer stuff too a
lot of indoor trainer work in that race
I I had this perspective of I chose to
do this and not only did I choose to do
this to suffer in this race I also pay a
lot of money to do it right and I was
there voluntarily when things got hard
on the run what I kept going back to you
was living my life every day as a trans
person is so much harder than what I'm
doing right now and that was the
perspective that sort of guided me and
you know maybe be present in that race
now when I finished the race I crossed
the finish line you know first an
Ironman first race as a man and the
volunteer who was giving me the medal
said congratulations you are an iron
woman no gave me the memory no like rain
on the parade and it was devastating at
the time clearly I still use it as a I
see no was it Mike Riley you said that
like no no as a volunteer who is okay
yeah Riley called me a male or female
you are an Ironman is that that's the
phrase yeah yeah and I think I didn't
even see that coming for me that was a
real moment of being like I just did the
hardest race of my
if I've been running out here you know
working out for 11 and a half hours and
this is what you know I've met with for
this accomplishment but it was probably
the first moment also that I let myself
have one minute to be upset about it and
then said that's that's on them that's
not about me right and that was a real
turning point for me I think because it
it symbolized my focus you know I wasn't
going to internalize other people's [ __ ]
anymore mm-hmm
yeah that's a that's a strong move you
know and I think you know that that
epiphany that that as hard as Iron Man
is it's not as hard as living your life
you know in in the skin of someone else
right it's not as hard as being a
closeted transgendered person is a
pretty powerful epiphany that I would
imagine you know it was kind of a brick
in a you know an early brick and that
wall of realizing that you know at some
point you were gonna be an advocate for
change yeah I know first before that was
knocking down all of the walls that I
had already created for so many years
and I think that was early part of
gaining that confidence back of I was
such a confident young kid and I look
back on that and think about those
middle years and it's really sad to me
like I was just such a confident and
outgoing young person and then I started
to get these messages that who I was was
wrong and I started to not change who I
was but suppress and to remove yeah
exactly
and you know having that moment of being
confident enough to say other people
have their own stuff and how they see me
is none of my business
that was a big first step to say three
maybe it's freedom incredibly freeing
and and maybe maybe I might have the
strength to be that public person who
doesn't exist right now uh-huh
up to that point had you had the
opportunity to meet any other trans
assets no Wow and living in New York
yeah still yeah and no you know there I
know we're gonna talk about the website
that you've created but prior to that
like no online resource for people that
were going through what you were going
through and wanted to be athletic yeah
an opportunity no community nothing on
YouTube nothing online in terms of
resources no policies that I could find
that were applicable to me so I really
felt like I was you know back to you
being in high school isolated and alone
yeah well there's a difference between
completing an Ironman and making six
Team USA's right it's it right yeah at
six
so you made five national teams as
basically an ITU try triathlete or do
athlete athlete's up we're all of those
in duathlon and then one in China in
triathlon right so how do you jump from
you know Ironman Arizona or Ironman
Florida into becoming this Elite ITU
triathlete well I think for me it was
really that I don't like cold water
first of all taught myself how to swim
yeah second it was super short yeah for
the tries but for Duathlon there's no
swim so Duathlon has run bike run and
you know something that could totally
bypass all of the discomfort that I felt
in triathlon which happened at the pool
mm-hmm so you know I started before my
transition I would be presenting
masculine Li you know looking
essentially like I do now going to the
pool having to use a women's restroom
because there's only two ways to the
pool it's either through the men's
locker room or the women's locker room
so having to use the facilities get
myself to the pool in a room in swimsuit
and you know what that did for me and my
soul was not hell really that's
interesting so easily get rid of all
that dispense with this morning well
part of it was also that I just I
realized very quickly that I was much
better at it than I was at triathlon
triathlon was fun because it was all new
things right and and the a whole new
learning curve and community and things
to get to know I mean you can really
geek out about it yeah for duathlon when
we were warming up for the Tri season in
New York there were March and April
Duathlon 's and that's really how I you
know dipped my toe in and realized I'm
just a better runner than I am a swim
right and I could maybe be competitive
at this I remember in the early days of
triathlon dating back to maybe you know
mid 80s early 80s when it was all neon
and you know Oakley's and all of that
and everyone was doing it in their
speedo yep that Duathlon kind of stood
on equal ground with triathlon and there
were do a salon stars they would you
would read about in the triathlon
magazines like who's the guy with the
long hair
Kenny Souza dumar he's like see I'm
older than you but like go back into the
history and they were like it was I
think it would I think it I think it was
Kenny Souza if I'm remembering correctly
but there were a couple guys like just
like long Mane's of hair and like lots
of neon and and duathlon was you know it
got a lot of print and at some point you
know triathlon kind of took over and
became you know what it is and duathlon
continue to co-exist but didn't quite
you know it kind of became a smaller
subculture you know in the Venn diagram
with multi-sport ya know certainly in
that smaller subculture part by the time
I had made it in I do remember seeing
like like beer companies sponsored race
series for growers and yeah and it was
really a big thing but for me it just
started off as a fun way to warm up for
triathlon and then you know realizing
that there was some potential there
right so how long before you dip your
toe into duathlon before you're like
making these national teams and you know
competing at the elite level you know I
think that it was a couple of years
actually I'm trying to think when I
first started do a fun 2015 was the
first national team that I made and I
wanted to compete in the national
championship in 2014 and didn't get
clearance in time so I basically had a
full year clearance being therapeutic
use exemption right and for taking is
don't you mean yeah for the testosterone
so that you can get around the doping
you haven't an aspect of the whole thing
yep and so in that process you know
trying to navigate that as a first time
person with no resources found
challenging and it didn't happen in 2014
so I basically had a full year of saying
this is my goal and
what I want to do and you know it became
in that year not just a goal for me as
an athlete as that be an amazing
experience but also as wow what might
the significance of this be for the
trans community for the lgbtq+ sports
community right well welcome to 2016 and
you're met with that opportunity right
so you begin your transition in 2010
2016 you make Team USA and you've got a
berth on the Duathlon squad that's gonna
compete in Spain at the World
Championships which is like an
incredible achievement for any athlete
you know like let alone the fact that
that you know you I mean essentially you
know genetically female and then
transitioned to male and are competing
with the top two athletes in America and
you make Team USA it's like an
extraordinary achievement it's
incredible and now you have your moment
your opportunity because the IOC is in
flux in terms of where it stands with
respect to transgender athletes at that
time right and you have this opportunity
to kind of insert yourself into the
comment period around how these
regulations are gonna get resolved
regarding you know the permissiveness of
someone like yourself to be able to
compete so you know talk me through that
yeah the race was in spring I believe
for qualifying for Team USA and as soon
as I qualified I knew that I would not
be allowed to compete internationally
based on the policies in place with the
International Olympic Committee so the
IOC at that time what was the what was
the rule of law so the rule was a two
year wait period for hormones as well as
a full lower surgery so internal and
external genital modification in order
to compete in sports and I knew right
away in making Team USA but I would
challenge the policy because I don't
feel like someone needs to modify their
body in order to fully be themselves or
to be a better athlete so that was not
part of my story of my transition
and I was prepared to challenge them on
that to say it's a human rights
violation like no one should have to
modify their body in order to
participate in sport right and and the
two-year thing like it's one year now
right yeah so so it was sort of this
perfect storm of events I made Team USA
and the very next day shot off emails to
ITU to USA Triathlon to IOC to try to
figure out will I be able to compete and
didn't get messages back and
consistently was trying to make contact
at the same time I was then featured in
ESPN magazine for the first time in a
profile that came out about me being a
trans athlete and the battle flag was
out prior to the body issue thing yeah
yeah well God so in talking to the
reporter you know it became half a
profile about me as an athlete and as a
trans person and then half a sort of
criticism of this policy and how they
wouldn't get contact back to you ESPN
and you know so it was this really great
highlight of how horrible the policy it
was how it didn't make sense how it was
not applicable in my case and that was
really when that article was published
no no joke within two weeks we had
contact with the IOC to talk about this
because it really painted them as no one
had any clue what they were doing at
that time yeah they were making
decisions but without the best facts
right right and and from what I
understand they then entertained
testimony from a variety of new experts
on the subject that and that changed
their minds on this yeah and so they had
this meeting after the ESPN article came
out and made a decision to change the
policy to remove the surgery requirement
and then to change the hormone
requirement from two years to one year
for transgender women which would mean
one year of their hormone level being
within the typical cisgender female
range and then totally eliminate the
hormone requirement for transgender men
right so basically you know an argument
can be made that that your example
I mean you in many ways single-handedly
you know make
helped make this change happen yeah they
really needed I think a name in a face
of a person who was it was impacting to
say all right let's actually think about
what this means and the T we
testosterone thing just just for clarity
for people who are listening you're
taking testosterone and the Tue
the therapeutic use exemption basically
dictates that yes you can take
testosterone but it has to fall within
the range of like you said like a
cisgendered male so it can't be used to
enhance performance by exceeding what a
normal kind of testosterone threshold
would be for a typical male athlete
right so how did they figure out what
that range is well the range is huge for
testosterone for men the ranges is huge
and so I'm not sure what the benchmark
is for those numbers but they have set
numbers and I have to do regular blood
work to make sure that I'm within those
ranges at all time and that I can be
tested at any time to to get my levels
right so you get permission to compete
you get to compete and then you go on to
make you know a bunch more of these
teams over the years and then you become
this race Walker yeah now we don't even
know what's gonna happen you know stick
around for another Olympiad maybe we'll
have our first Olympian transit wraps
out transgendered athlete perhaps you
know I think it it was really cool to
make this switch so I made the team for
2020 in Duathlon in April and then
decided to switch over just because I
have this opportunity to potentially
make the Olympic Trials and that's
really how it was set up my friend Pablo
Gomez trains with me in Chicago and he
is number five race Walker in the
country mm-hmm and little to my
knowledge at that time he was really
trying to recruit anyone but he told me
that he thought I need more bodies in
this sport
yeah he thought that I was good and I
was really well all it took to team
motivates me to give it a shot and it
was such a cool experience because as an
adult you know when was the last time
that you were a beginner at something
yeah when was the last time you know
something that you do all the time that
you show up and see it with fresh eyes
when was the last time you were a
beginner at something and then suddenly
not a beginner right yeah
in your case yeah and I really loved the
process though I loved the process of
figuring things out and there's so much
to figure out in racewalking with the
form and the way that the races are
structured and how the points work you
know it wasn't like I was gonna show up
at the Olympic Trials and make the
Olympic team unless I posted a 350 or
faster which no one at the race did it's
all based on points from from here on
out so I never went into that going I'm
going to be the first Olympian and I've
said this for you know the years that
I've been out that when we have our
first Olympian I will feel as proud as
if I was actually there because you know
I worked so hard to open these doors
but duathlon is not an Olympic sport so
there was never a shot and triathlon is
totally out of the question so this was
just an opportunity to really take that
next step of making the trials and
opening that door and now are you the
first out transgendered athlete to
compete in an Olympic Trials not in the
Olympic Trials but in the gender with
which they identify yes so in 2012 and
16 I believe or maybe it's 8 and 12
there was an athlete named Kealing
Godsey who is a trans man who competed
with women in the Olympic Trials
he made a social transition he/him
pronouns and his name is aquiline but he
but not not good not no medical no
medical translation at which which then
puts him in the position to compete with
women all right it gets confusing yeah
and I think you know really does and and
there's so much confusion and lack of
education around just not even
transgender athletes which is
complicated because of the categories
are so different and the levels of play
are so different but even just a general
understanding of what it means to be
transgender right and in preparation for
this I mean you started this this
website trans athlete to kind of rectify
this and and be a place for you know
people who were in your situation to go
to and I was looking through it and you
have a whole tab on terms and it's
basically a glossary that
mmm you know I feel like I know a little
bit about this and I was like wow I
didn't know that I didn't know that I
didn't know that like there's so much to
learn and it isn't I mean we like to
think of it as a very binary thing or a
black-and-white thing and it's very much
not that yeah and sport is very binary
and that is where it becomes a problem
right because our world is increasingly
not yeah more and more young people
identify as something other than totally
straight or cisgender you know they're
they're in flux their identity is fluid
more than ever yeah that makes a trick
that makes it really hard so yeah we're
this is a good point to kind of like
launch into the advocacy aspect of what
you do because I think it's one thing
for a transgender male like yourself to
you know compete against other men
distinguish yourself admirably like
that's something that we can all
celebrate it's more fraught with
controversy to be a transgender female
competing against females because we
have this tension between fairness and
inclusion right that I think is you know
what I learned preparing to talk to
Kendra is a much more nuanced issue than
I previously thought yeah but I still
think you know we we haven't figured out
you know a fantastic way of trying to
resolve these increasingly you know more
and more pressing problems around this
yeah the funny thing is we have figured
in that we have okay you know see here's
gonna be edified yeah I know these
educate me here's my perspective on this
right we have figured it out just the
way the narrative around it is not
accurate we live in a time right now
where anyone can tweet anything out and
people will see it and take it as fact
and then you know the responsibility of
the person who is it it's affecting to
defend or refute that statement you know
is is a challenge because people don't
read the apologies they don't read the
corrections they read the headline take
it as fact and move on and what we've
seen is that a lot of people have
created these false narratives are
around transgender people and trans
athletes and you know we've been able to
compete in the indie Olympics since 2010
since 2010 there have been zero
transgender Olympians right
we are not dominating in sport mm-hmm at
the highest levels over 25 states have
policies in place right now at the high
school level that say that trans
athletes can compete in the gender with
which they identify we are not seeing
high school transgender athletes
dominating across the board in sport and
so you know we have been participating
we have been participating with our
peers and in the category that aligns
with our gender and it's been working
fine uh-huh walk me through the I mean
like this sort of example that gets
raised all the time
is in transgendered women competing in
in combat sports right so if you have
like an MMA fighter or boxing or
something where you know physical harm
is a is a reality and you take an
athlete who has lived you know the
majority of their life as a male and
then has a medical transition to female
to what extent is that individual still
living with the musculature and the bone
density and all the like that gets
associated with their male upbringing
and then taking that into the ring and
you know potentially creating a fairness
issue and also a physical harm issue to
their fellow competitor like this is
this is the this is like kind of like
where the battle lines are being drawn I
suppose so yeah talk me through this and
I think combat sports and powerlifting
are the two areas right we're seeing I
saw like a vice documentary about power
lifters on that RF you saw it
transgender power lifters do you see
that yeah I don't see interesting I
learned a lot but anyway go ahead yeah
so I think that what what we're doing
though is we're working in broad
generalizations of you know when people
are thinking about that person stepping
into the ring that they're thinking
about six foot four you know ex-military
seal right like going into fighting some
five to woman and it just doesn't work
like
in that sport because it's weight based
and classification right they're evenly
matched what we've seen is that for
transgender women after their one year
of cross hormone therapy that they are
on the same competitive level as their
female peers and so we haven't we
haven't seen a case of somebody coming
in and dominating in combat sports
there was one MMA fighter Fallon Fox who
she was not undefeated she did not
dominate in the ring and she's often
used as the example of you know why this
is not okay she was forced out of the
sport because she couldn't get matches
anymore because of all of the
discrimination that she faced not only
as a transgender woman but as a woman of
color and all of that sort of plays into
how people are being treated but you can
imagine a scenario like let's say you
did it like some guy comes out of the
Navy SEALs you know just basically a
beast and and specifically trained to be
a killer or whatever decides to become
to transition into being a woman enters
the ring you know in some kind of combat
sport like do you not see like that that
could potentially raise an issue or do
you think that this is all like a you
know this can all be managed you know I
certainly think that in that scenario I
mean that is an extreme right okay
that's sort of it thought experiment you
have to like play in the extremes to see
what could potentially happen right and
you know people are like well what if
seven foot one NBA player transitions
and wants to go play in the WNBA right
right and there's all these what ifs and
these situations just aren't happening
and we're talking about the extreme
outskirts of the already elite huh when
we're talking about these situations so
I mean if something like that came up of
course I would look at that and probably
have some thoughts about it but it's
just simply not happening right so in
other words in the fairness versus
inclusion you know conversation it's not
a matter of tipping the scales towards
inclusion over fairness you're thinking
that these things can co-exist and that
it's not problematic absolutely and I
think transgender women and girls have
been can
with women and girls for years without
problem with their peers and they've
been participating on sports teams at
the at the high school level at the
elite level and there has been no
problems right and I think that what the
discrimination against transgender women
and girls actually does is takes away
from the real issue about the disparity
in sport and the gendered gender
inequity that exists in the sport what
we really should be focusing on is we
women sports and how we uplift women's
sports and you know I think that
targeting transgender women does not do
that it doesn't help the real problem is
the the lack of access the lack of
resources the pay inequity that exists
within women's sports because of
systemic discrimination
yeah well certainly that's that's for
real you know I've just put up a couple
podcasts that kind of go pretty deep
into that and that's a huge problem but
are there are there are there in the
track and field context are there
transgendered women who are you know
killing it competing against there
aren't tell me tell me I don't know I
mean I should I just do any research so
I actually don't know
track-and-field is the one area that you
know when people are talking about this
across the country they're looking at
two transgender girls in Connecticut who
are high-school student athletes who
last year went 1-2 it's state when we're
talking about dominating when they went
to Nationals one didn't even compete and
the other placed 30th and 31st in her
two races and so you know yes they have
won races but dominating is inaccurate
right and and I think that you know
people really pick up on those stories
and these are two young black women and
you know I bring up race again because
race is absolutely a part of this you
know being a transgender woman is
absolutely a part of this women in
sports both cisgender and trans have had
their bodies policed for years for
decades and it's by targeting
transgender women and it's been focusing
on people's bodies I think that we
really prepare
that issue within women's sports well
that you know what happens in track and
field I mean the the case study that
gets brought up conflates intersects
because it's all about caster Semenya
semenya right and whether or not she
should be allowed to compete and that
brings up a different you know kind of
ripple in the you know fairness versus
inclusion conversation because this is a
human being who was just born a certain
way yeah and so should she be unable to
compete and penalize because this is how
the universe or God or whatever you want
to call it made her in a certain way I
can't
you know proclaim to have the answer to
that but it's an interesting you know
conversation that needs to be had yeah
absolutely and I think it's really
important that we that we remember that
there's not just there's not one way to
be a man there's not just one way to be
a woman and there are certainly
categories that they have for hormones
at the elite level of testing right but
there's not just one way to be a trans
person either and there's not just one
way to have a body that excels in sport
so the body that a swimmer would have is
going to be different than what would be
helpful for an elite sprinter of course
or a rower you know so when we make
these generalizations about trans women
dominating a sport or someone like
caster Semenya you know having her
makeup being able to dominate in the
sport I think that we reach real
dangerous territory hmm yeah you know
she found the sport that is that is
great for her yeah and she is no
question about that it gifted athlete is
but it's so interesting that because she
is a black woman because she is more
masculine presenting that that she has
been targeted in a way that other
athletes have not other incredible
female athletes like Katie ledecky
who beat people in Rio by an entire pool
link not even on the same TV so I was
dominant you know absolutely swimmer you
can imagine has not been questioned
about her gender and to my knowledge has
not been tested for her hormone levels
and things like that and I don't and I
don't think that she should be and I
don't think any athlete should be you
know because that's a real step
for years women in the Olympics were
tested
they were gender tested sex tested
really but there were these things
called naked parades where female
athletes would have to strip down nude
and parade themselves in front of a
panel of judges so that they could be
visually inspected along with having
gynecological exams and and others like
that in order to make sure that they
were actually a woman yeah well on the
Katie ledecky
you know caster sort of rubric you know
it brings up a broader conversation
about what should be considered an
illegal performance enhancer in general
right there there are exogenous
substances that any athlete can take
that we're gonna enhance performance and
we can talk about testosterone in a
moment but you know Michael Phelps has a
crazy wingspan and giant feet and castor
you know is who she is and katie is who
she is
and you know if somebody is born with
you know a very high level of
testosterone and that's just how their
body functions you know at what point
does that become an unfair competitive
advantage versus just a competitive
advantage right where do we draw the
line between something that is exogenous
and something that is you know
indigenous to that to that individual
and I think with respect to trans women
athletes they do police testosterone
levels right like they happen to be
within a certain you know range in order
for them to get permission to compete
against other women is that how it works
yes and in their not testing cisgender
athletes and nor should they I don't
think athletes should be tested in that
way but it is a different situation for
transgender women mm-hmm yeah I think
it's gonna get even more complicated
when you know we start seeing genetic
modifications and CRISPR and all of that
yeah my brains complicated now I didn't
do it I don't know how are you gonna be
able to you know figure out what's fair
and what's not at that point but well
and that's the thing I think that we are
all just trying our best for the most
part there are certainly long
makers out there policymakers who have
never spoken to a transgender athlete
who lacked the education and
understanding about what it actually
means to be trans and transition and are
making policies that impact our ability
to participate with our peers I think
that it is incredibly complicated even
as an advocate for me to talk about
because at the high school level I
believe the policy should be different
than at the college or the elite level
of participation in play and so to break
down the different categories you know
it becomes incredibly complicated yeah
well I want to get into some of your
advocacy around you know the shifting
regulatory landscape here but when did
you first realize that that you kind of
had a voice in this movement and that
you were gonna shoulder that
responsibility it may have been as early
as my first decision to come out
publicly which was 2010 after that
Ironman race I wrote an article for The
Advocate and you know to hit Send on
that article made me realize that this
is something I'll never be able to to go
back from and having the opportunity to
be in the New York Times in 2011 I had
done the New York City triathlon as
female in 2009 and then as male in 2011
if there's one else done that no I was
maybe maybe after but I was at first
that they knew of and that's the thing
with all of this is like first-known I'm
the first known out translate but I
think that that was the moment where I
decided like I am going to put myself
out there and most of it is to be who I
needed when I was younger yeah yeah I
mean that's kind of your mantra right be
the person that you needed you know when
you were a young person yeah and I think
also somebody said to me since The Times
article came out recently that you know
I it's I say that a lot and that's a
really important thing for me because I
get messages all the time from young
trans kids but also from their parents
and it's just so incredibly impactful to
be able to see the impact of being a
role model even if I'm not reaching
everybody right of the people who are
seeing me are being
really moved by it and it's changing
their lives somebody said to me recently
you know not just I'm not just being the
person I needed when I was younger but
I'm being the person that young people
today need to see yeah whether they're
trans or sis it doesn't matter that that
more people need to know that trans
people exist that we can live happy
authentic safe successful lives and that
we are here and that yeah basically that
mainstream culture and society can see
you thriving and doing well and and you
know kind of you know as a healthy
individual in the world as as kind of
this lighthouse
you know irrespective of whether you
know that person reading that are seeing
that has anybody who's trans in their
you know inner circle or not just that
alone I think is a powerful thing
because it's one thing to be you know
profiled in the advocate or an out
magazine or any of these you know kind
of you know publications of that world
but it's another thing all together to
have like this big profile in the New
York Times right you know and that's
that's the transition from you being a
mouthpiece and a spokesperson amongst
your community to being kind of this
beacon that existing culture at large
yeah and then I started to seek that out
when I saw that that was an opportunity
that that was an option for me mm-hmm
I really started to seek out
opportunities to be that person it's
funny going through my emails recently
like way way back cleaning out the inbox
I found some that I was writing to all
my friends who were authors and writers
at publication saying if you're ever
doing a story about transgender athletes
please contact me I'm trying to position
myself as an expert and so it was really
something that I had planned to when I
created the website you know as a
resource that sort of gave me more
opportunities to speak and to you know
be someone that people would go to for
information and I really tried to set it
up so that I could be that person that
just didn't exist at that time how did
the ESPN Body Issue happen for you that
was like 2016 right yeah so in the first
ESPN article I had mentioned to the
author
hey if you're picking people for the
body issue I'd love to do it and she
said the others really making it happen
make it move that's a heat check it was
it was I think I know I think after it
left my mouth I was like what did I just
do because she said that her editor was
actually the editor of that issue and
that she would pass it along and I
didn't really think much about it
afterwards but in February I got a call
to ask if I would be in it and you know
instantly said yes and they said well
you know this is a nude shoot right like
this is totally naked I was like yeah
yeah I know I'm like no no photoshopping
like no clothes and I was like yeah I
mean like let's do it for so long I was
so insecure about being myself and about
existing in this world and I thought
what an amazing opportunity like my body
is my machine I work very hard on it and
also I think it's great for people to
see a trans person in this issue so it
was just a great opportunity yeah and
you look great you were ripped yeah you
know and I think it's yeah look that's a
that's that's you know the image I mean
you know the symbology of that like is
super powerful and to see you know the
scars and and and all of that you know
all of it you know and to see how you
present physically in that form as an
elite athlete like it that was a big
deal man
yeah there was a lot around that because
so often trans people are reduced to
their bodies right when we're talking
about how people show up in sport and
and the fetishization of trans people in
general it's it's all about our bodies
that's what people are interested in
when they're talking about transition
and surgeries and what's in my pants and
so on right and it was really empowering
to be able to put myself out there but
the pushback that I got from some people
was that it was an inaccurate or
unattainable representation of being
trans which I thought was really
interesting because you know my body is
not everyone's body and there's no wrong
way to have a body but my body is
trained through you know 20-plus hours
yeah training a week
well the body issue is about inspiration
and aspera
right you know you're not you're not
there to you know present the every man
or every woman version of that right
right and I think some people really got
wrapped into that because it was a trans
body but I think the inspiration and
aspiration piece I mean you're spot-on
they're like what I'm talking I'm always
saying that I don't want my story to be
inspirational I want it to be
aspirational I want people to see me and
even if they're not an athlete be
compelled to go and be more
authentically themselves in this world
and and not feel like they have to give
up their passions in order to do so the
tectonic plates of law are shifting
rapidly and you're a very you know
you're very outspoken on Twitter and
through your various channels about
what's happening right now I think we
have eight state bills at the moment
that are attempting to prevent
transgender kids from competing in high
school sports is that correct you have a
recreational sports just over nine now
nine we've got this law in South Dakota
SD HB 10:57 that you've been talking a
lot about that would make it a crime to
provide puberty blockers to transgender
or aspiring transgender minors right is
that correct phraseology yep trans youth
yeah there's a law in Arizona there's
certain things going on with the Supreme
Court right now making it potentially
legal to fire workers who are LGBTQ plus
right yep
Utah the ACLU is involved in all of this
like walk me through a legal landscape
what's happening now first maybe it you
know add altitude and then we can drill
down on some of these laws and and you
know what you what you see is happening
yeah so I think it's important to say
first of all at the high school level I
believe it's something like seventeen
states have fully inclusive policies
where there are no hoops to jump through
for transgender high school student
athletes they say who they are and they
get to compete on that team and there
are several other states probably up to
the total comp being 35 states in total
that allow trans people to participate
in some capacity even if they have some
sort of you know
check system or someone has to make a
decision it's weird that there's laws at
all I wouldn't even think that there
would be laws likes just whatever you
want to do to go do go play sports so
they're not lost so they are in each of
these states they're made by the high
school State Athletic Association which
is why there are several states that
have no policy at all amendment are
states like Texas and Indiana that
require student athletes to participate
according to their birth certificate and
so we have this whole range across the
50 states of being super inclusive and
no problems and then not being able to
participate at all mmm I would imagine
it breaks down between red and blue it
doesn't it doesn't there are some there
are some surprising you know moments of
in-between but what we are seeing right
now is state lawmakers in different
states are trying to make house bills or
have presented house bills to have the
government regulate what happens in high
school sports so there are states that
have had policies like Washington State
for example was one of the first states
to create a policy for transgender
student athletes in the early save 2010
to 2012 time period they've been
existing with no problems in their state
whatsoever and that that law says what
that's their policy of the high school
State Association policy says if you're
if you are a transgender student athlete
you say what your gender is you can
compete with the gender without question
and there's no switching back and forth
that doesn't happen you know people are
I am a trans man I want to compete with
boys and men and that's how they compete
and there's no there's no hoops to jump
through Washington is one of the states
now where government has stepped in and
said we don't want transgender girls
competing with girls and some of the
bills don't say girls specifically but
that's essentially what it is because no
one's really worried about the trans boy
competing with boys you know when when
they're bringing up the sort of
narrative that they're presenting is is
all about transgender girls and so there
are now nine states that have these
bills on the table to try to prevent at
the government level what has already
been working in the high school level
yeah well I suppose I mean I would
imagine
a lot of fear-mongering around all of
that the possibility does exist that
some kid you know who weighs 250 pounds
could decide okay I now just you know as
a prank or as a you know social
experiment to say I identify as female
and I'm gonna go play you know girls
basketball or whatever right this is a
broad sweeping generalization I think
that's really what the people who are
presenting this bills are relying on
right is like this idea that it's it's
not just the fear of a transgender girl
competing with girls the way that
they're framing it is that they don't
want a boy to be competing with girls so
first of all there are policies in place
that prevent boys and men from playing
girls and women's sports right so we're
not seeing someone who is a boy trying
to compete with girls and transgender
girls are girls and so to frame it up in
that way negates their identity
completely but if somebody has socially
transitioned but not medically
transitioned what's the difference so
there are policies and the policies
address that some states say it's okay
we're not checking hormones and some go
buy hormones the ones that go buy
hormones are a lot more restrictive for
young people because you have to think
like to make that decision at a young
age is is a lot it's not just on that
person who may know truly who they are
but they need the family support they
need the insurance they need access to
appropriate medical care and there are a
lot of factors that go into that got it
okay and what about these laws that are
that are potentially or this law I guess
in in South Dakota that could
potentially criminalize the provision
you know by health care providers of
puberty blockers like walk me through
walk me through the arguments on both
sides and why this is kind of like a
test case out there that everyone's kind
of paying attention to yeah so multiple
states have now come up with these House
bills that want to criminalize providing
gender affirming care to transgender
youth what this means is that kids are
gonna die I mean really when I think
about my own
I think I got to that point on that
birthday where I thought I can I will
not be here for another birthday if I
continue to live my life like this
because of the mental health concerns
and it's not mental health concerns its
existing in the world in total right
like the stresses that the world and me
being who I was and how people saw me is
certainly you know caused mental health
concerns I guess seek write it that way
but but it was more like I I just
couldn't see myself being here anymore
right like I couldn't see a future for
myself I didn't feel like there was a
place for me and it's been proven that
providing gender affirming care for
young people reduces suicidality in
transy right the argument would be that
that you know the minors brain and kind
of emotional state are in flux and
continue to be developing at that age so
it's too young
like let's we need to wait like we can't
we can't move forward with this kind of
this set of procedures at this time and
we need to allow this person to mature
until they you know have an adequate
level of conviction and maturation to
make that decision of sound mind you
know I think with so much none of these
decisions are being made lightly you
know I think that's something that
people need to remember is that no one
is transitioning for an advantage in
sport it's simply raising the hat right
right like what trans people have to
face in the rest of their lives would
never offset a gold medal or a state
championship right people are not
transitioning to gain athletic advantage
and in the case of trans youth us to
separate from sport these are decisions
that need to be made with parents and
with health care providers right there's
no way for a 16 year old to just go get
puberty blockers and so what some of
these bills are doing is saying that it
would be a crime for a doctor to provide
gender affirming care to a patient who
wants it and and and their family right
then their parents who have had this
conversation and know that this is the
best decision for them it would make it
illegal for doctors to do their jobs so
if they
if they don't provide if there's a if
there's a minor who wants to transition
mm-hmm and really wants these puberty
blockers denying that person the ability
to avail themselves of that at that time
would allow puberty to move forward
right and assuming that that young
person's conviction remains true and
they continue to wish to transition it
then is it then becomes a much more
complicated procedure down the line
because of you know the development that
ensues by virtue of puberty correct
right that is accurate and we've seen
you know mental health benefits for
young trans people who receive gender
affirming care for puberty blockers so
puberty blockers would happen maybe for
a year or two years before cross hormone
therapy and that's as you said to sort
of delay the onset of any sort of
physical changes that might be
associated with puberty you know I think
about what my experience would have been
like as a young person if I knew who I
was
and was able to exist in the world fully
as that person I would have had a
totally different life and I think I
would have I would have bypassed a lot
of the pain that I felt in high school
and college and out of college when I
didn't know what that what those
feelings were or or have the words to
put to them what are the mental health
statistics with respect to trans youth
like in terms of the incidence of
depression and suicide and you know
other kind of related mental issues yeah
it's 41% of transgender people attempt
to take their own life forty one percent
forty one percent and so you think about
of transgender people in general or you
have trans youth trans re transit youth
being what like other 21 or something 23
or 25 or privately you know for us to
have the opportunity to provide care for
someone and not to do that is putting
them in a position where we're telling
them that their lives are not worthy and
is there any validity or wisdom to the
argument that you know minds do change
and you know I know like ideas that I
had when I was
person you know he's like I don't know
what I was thinking at that time right
like yeah that's where the fear is it is
their legitimacy to that because you
know it seems to me you could make
somewhat of a cogent argument or around
that yeah and with the health care
system there are steps in place to make
sure that this is a true and
authentically held identity before any
of this would start to happen and so you
know in my own case I had to see a
therapist for a very long time really a
year before I could get hormones and it
was to make sure that essentially
vetting you through this whole thing
yeah and I think that has changed a
little bit there was a requirement but
someone had like this lived experience
of transition and you know those sort of
requirements have have gone away but
these are decisions that people are
making with their parents with their
families and with their health care
providers really talking through what
the outcomes would be right you know I
think the fear is like this is not what
that's not the framework that
politicians are setting this up against
what what we're seeing is this is an
election year these are conservative
candidates in conservative states yeah
it's not it's it's it's not a mistake
that this is all happening in an
election year and marriage equality is
no longer on the table for us to drive a
wedge in between voters and so this for
whatever reason transgender people and
specifically trans athletes has become
that hot-button topic yeah
yeah it's interesting when you look at
it through through that lens and and it
kind of pushes that you know severity
and fear button by saying you know in
criminal you're literally criminalizing
this like there's a fine and there's
also the potential going to jail for a
year so any doctor that would like you
know go through with you know a patient
on this protocol is looking at jail time
right
it's weren't doing their job and that's
this is South Dakota but there are
similar laws like this you know on the
across the country yes country yeah yeah
and it's terrifying because what it does
is it sets up people you know even if
this law doesn't pass and so by the time
we're done recording this podcast we'll
have we'll know what happened in South
Dakota
oh well it's happened today right
- the clock today they're bugging on it
and 2 o'clock
yeah sorry show you Blake check it out
is awake right go on the internet and
find out so you know when when we find
this out HB 10:57 go ahead even if this
doesn't pass the narrative around it is
so incredibly dangerous because it sets
us up for people to not treat trans
people as people right it's already
putting out there that yeah The Trevor
Project is a organization that handles
mental health concerns and is like a
hotline for LGBTQ plus youth and they've
seen a huge spike in the number of calls
from South Dakota since the announcement
of this bill you know this is impacting
young people because you were telling
them like you're not worthy your
existence your very existence is up for
debate like you can't imagine how that
might feel yeah so how do you compare
self as an advocate like how do you
think about how you speak about these
issues you know the kind of language
that you choose to use and and how you
see your set like like are you gonna be
out there you know on the front lines
like you know pounding your fist or are
you trying to be somebody with open arms
who's on the receiving end of these you
know trans youth like how do you like
what's your vibe with all of it there
are so many different components to it
because social media is such an
incredible tool both for my advocacy but
also for my visibility and for my
ability to connect with and mentor other
people and so I would say you know many
many trans people who have come out who
have been in sport that we've heard
stories about or read about I have
mentored in someway reached out to them
help them through their process I get
contacted by trans kids across the
country who are trying to stay in the
sport who are having issues with coaches
or policies and so I'm in this position
where I get to mentor people and parents
and and provide education to colleges
and universities through my speaking you
know and then also use Twitter as a way
to spread information and use Instagram
as a way to spread information
and part of that is simply by being
visible I can help to expand people's
understanding about what it means to be
trans yeah I mean you must be the most
visible trans athlete out there I
believe I am yeah I think you are and
for me it's really important to approach
everything as a sort of learning
opportunity you know there's this idea
of like meet people where they're at and
I certainly do that but I also want to
bring them along a little bit all right
and so I know that most people that I'm
talking to even if they say something
that's offensive it's not intended to be
offensive in most cases yeah have I
offended you at all
you have no however sorry yeah you have
not cuz I mean here's the thing like I
feel like I I know a little bit yeah
but I'm also I have a self awareness
around the level of ignorance that I
have around this too and I think most
people out there kind of know a little
bit and maybe they're not interested in
knowing much more about that right and
what I've noticed about you is is you
have you know you have a lot of
equanimity with people like you you
don't get upset and you know you have an
acute ability to kind of communicate and
connect with people and you do meet them
where they're at in the sense that like
you're not gonna chastise somebody
because they didn't you know they didn't
understand that they had their
phraseology off or something like that
and instead you look at it as an
opportunity to kind of you know educate
them a little bit more yeah I mean
here's the thing you don't know what you
don't know so I wrote everything you
know for four years I didn't know I was
transgender and I'm a trans person now
talking about identity right like you
don't know what you don't know and so
but there's a responsibility when you
have that awareness when you have that
education to do better and so I feel
like I can go into conversations and
treat people with dignity and respect
and help them come to a better
understanding about transgender identity
and what it means and you know some of
these horrible policies that are being
put out there and help move them along
and that is the way that I think that I
can create social change it's not by
engaging in Twitter Wars or responding
the trolls or you know and and I do
respond to people who
against me or who sometimes say things
because I want my response that's with
love and respect to be an example for
other people yeah in sub tweeted or do
you like retweet it with with adding the
thing you know you know what I mean
there's a difference yeah yeah I guess
you can respond and it goes below or you
have retweeted and your responses above
I think it probably depends on what it
is yeah but also there's a lot of
private messages that happen and you
know I think that more than the stories
the articles the documentaries and stuff
like that I'm really proud of my ability
to communicate with other people and and
help them understand who I am and it's a
very different situation when you know
somebody who has that identity right
when you when you have a conversation
with me and you've never talked to a
trans person before I feel like that's a
moment where I can help be a good
reflection of our community and even
though I am just or myself and can't
represents all trans people you know I
can I can let people know like I'm a
regular person and I like a lot of the
same things that you like and we can
find common ground and and take away
some of the scariness and the the
concerns that people have about trans
people because the way that these
politicians are positioning us is as not
human yeah yeah we're scared of what we
don't know ran when it's the other and
it's easier to create a bogeyman around
that right much harder to sit across
from you getting to know you to you know
have that perspective yeah you know
other than the laws that we've kind of
touched on where do you see the biggest
battle lines being drawn right now like
where where is the the war being waged
what's what's the fight that needs to be
fought is it over like the bathrooms is
it over you know these state laws and
sports or you know even outside of
sports like what what is the civil
rights situation at the moment you see
it yeah it really is around transgender
youth and around health care and I think
that we'll see these policies at the
state levels go through or not go
through about preventing transgender
athletes in the high school level from
competing and
we're gonna see you know all of these I
believe it's over a dozen of these bills
about health care and that is a really
dangerous situation it is a sort of a
gateway law right to prevent trans
people from existing in public you know
you deny me my ability to have
appropriate affirming healthcare and
very bad things can happen right I mean
that's denying somebody's personhood I
suppose on a fundamental level and and
that's gonna precipitate you know a
domino effect of you know from mental
health you know of mental health issues
all the way to suicide yeah yeah and I
you know I think I also want to be very
careful of framing this up just around
mental health certainly mental health is
what will lead us to no longer existing
right but but it there's so much more
than that I think that there is this
narrative of trans people being mentally
ill that people faced and fought for so
long you know the mental health issues
that we're facing the whatever the
depression and suicidality and and
things like that are the result of not
being treated like humans mm-hmm and so
it's not inherently a good diaper
important point it's not inherently that
because I'm trans I am susceptible to
mental illness or mental health concerns
it's that the world treats us in symptom
absolutely yeah you know is there a
particular law that you would like to
see passed or overturned no I think that
we need federal protections that include
gender identity yeah and expanding
expanding like the Civil Rights Act
basically is brave saying yeah because
when we start to have these state
policies you know we saw the domino
effect here of having one state put up
this healthcare policy and then you know
within a matter of three weeks meaning
the numbers are climbing so we don't
know there's no current out transgender
person that we know of that's competing
in the upcoming Olympics in Tokyo yeah
not that I know of at this time but a
lot of the trials are still coming up
the the you know competitions that are
going to sort out who actually goes so
it is possible it is absolutely possible
that this would
year and what's the vision that you hold
like four years ten years from now like
where would you like to see the state of
culture and sport and we can kind of
wrap it up with that I think right yeah
where did where is this going if you if
you you know if it was up to you I think
that sport is one of the most magical
places for people to exist I think that
sport is a vehicle for social change and
the change that happens within sports in
terms of policies and acceptance and
inclusion can really be a guide for the
rest of the world mm-hmm
and we've seen it in the past and I
think that we are we're at a crossroads
right now where how we treat inclusion
in sport is going to reflect in the rest
of society yeah absolutely I mean I
think I read somewhere that that you
know you were inspired by some of the
great you know activist athletes out
there you know I don't know who in
particular but you know there's these
iconic images that come to mind from you
know Muhammad Ali to you know the closed
you know gloved fist on the podium at
the Olympics and the ability of the
athlete to you know move culture forward
and advance conversation around ideas
that people are resistant to is a thing
you know and I think that you're
somebody who who is on you know the sort
of you know razor's edge of this in a
new and broader mmm you know
conversation around civil rights and
what that means and what kind of culture
and society do we want to be in and live
in and I think your advocacy is is
admirable and you know I'm I'm in awe of
your athletic talent and also your
strength and your courage to put
yourself out there you know you know in
harm's way I think in in in a very real
way like you're putting yourself at
peril to get this message across and you
know that may get lost in the
conversation but I would imagine that
that's a very real consideration for you
as well your safety so it's important
work that you're doing and I wish you
all the best
thank you for what you do thank you you
know athletes have a platform and I
think that athletes have social capital
not just in the United States but in the
world and we look at Olympians
differently we look at professional
athletes differently we even look at
high school in collegiate athletes
differently and so I think it's an
incredible position for me to be in to
have this platform you know to have a
Nike sponsorship and and things like the
New York Times article and to be able to
express the people the concerns about
the realities facing transgender people
not just in sport but in our community
as a whole you know I want people to to
know that they can be their authentic
self and continue to play the sports
that they love and continue to do their
passions and not have to compromise any
part of their identity to hide any part
of their identity because when we are
authentic about who we are and when we
are able to and it's not safe for
everyone to come out but if we are able
to do that you know your entire world
opens up and it not just impacts you but
it affects the people around you and I
think that's really how social change is
created you know is that ripple effect
and so you know my hope is that me
waking up every single day and living in
Austin life can be my advocacy and you
know that all the other parts I have to
talk about are you know part of that but
I really just want people to see that
that I am possible that they are
possible because I impossible and you
know nothing is nothing is off limits
like people can have a future but the
future that I didn't see for myself when
I was younger it exists and for that for
the for the person who's listening who's
you know living you know a secret double
life or just you know is afraid to come
out what are the you know what is what
is the kind of message that you would
like to impart to that person yeah there
are so many factors that go into one's
ability to come out and it's you know
now with laws and policies like this
about access to care and safety there
are financial concerns and family
support concerns for young
there are you know very real
possibilities that people will lose
their house or their you know apartment
and housing their employment and things
like that and so there are so many
factors that go into it that I would
never tell somebody that they have to
come out you know I think this is one of
the problems that we have in
professional sports is like we are
looking for that out gay male athlete in
the big four sports like when are they
going to come out there are so many
factors in any lgbtq+ person's existence
of of whether or not to come out you
know my message is to that person would
just be that that they are valid and
their identity is valid and real and
that they are worthy of love and respect
and dignity and if that person is
looking you know online for some support
and resources where can you direct those
people other than you of course trans
athlete calm yeah trans athletes calm
for young people glisten GL Sen is a
great resource for families PFLAG is a
great resource and there are so many
organizations that are doing work around
advocating for trans people in different
areas of life but you know the biggest
thing that has made a difference for me
is that human connection of having
somebody to talk to you so I actually
just opened myself up to send me a DM
like I talked to you talk to you a ton
of people and what I will maybe be most
proud of is not the accomplishments that
I have athletically but knowing that
I've been a part of hundreds of school
projects for young people you know of
that I've had video chats and message
exchanges with hundreds of young people
and that it's made a real difference
having just that one person reach out
and say like I know what you're going
through or you know you're gonna be okay
yeah alright man well hit up Chris in
the in the DM
Chris measure get your terms down by
going to the glossary on trans athlete
calm study up on that and get your knee
sort it out right yes we can start
training again next step you have
surgery on that coming up or
what are you just letting it heal or
what's going on yeah I'm exploring my
options I you know I want to continue to
be competitive to compete at a level and
not sure if that definitely means
surgery or what I can do but we'll get
it started out cool well enjoy the rest
of your time in LA and come back anytime
i man I appreciate it thank you thank
you so much all right peace
[Music]